former attorney general eric holder
believes our voting rights are in
serious danger right now and his new
book our unfinished march is a history
of voting in this country and a picture
of the situation we're in today a dark
picture at that he describes quote our
warped senate our gerrymandered house
our malaportioned electoral college and
our politicized supreme court which are
the reasons america is a democracy in
need of serious renovation
close quote holder is chairman of the
national democratic redistricting
committee which challenges electoral
maps and he joins us now uh mr attorney
general thank you for being here thanks
for having me uh you describe a picture
of american democracy flawed in all
three branches of government and i want
to get to that and the solutions but i
want to begin with the judicial branch
if roe is overturned and abortion rights
are no longer guaranteed in this country
you would support the end of the
filibuster to pass a law providing
access tell me how that might work
yeah i think that what's likely to
happen is that the decision may actually
occur that roe is overturned i suspect
the language that you saw in the leaked
illegal opinion will not appear that's
caustic i think that is it's overheated
but if roe were to be overturned and if
we could get past the filibuster you
could pass a federal
statute that would declare as the law of
the land women would have the right to
uh reproductive choices that the
american people support i think that's
something we have to understand here the
supreme court is about to do something
that is inconsistent with the will of
the american people and upon which the
american people have relied for the past
50 years everything you write about in
this book is about making sure majority
rules in this country and we have a
system at the moment where minority
rules in some in some cases removing the
filibuster would be a way to make sure
majority positions take hold one
criticism would be that it creates a
ping pong effect republicans come to
power they ban abortion access democrats
come back and empower they flip the
light switch the other direction what do
you say to that well we have to believe
in the american people and believe in in
our system the ping-pong effect had
would be modified by the fact that
through the electoral process if a party
comes in takes power and puts in place
positions that are inconsistent again
with the desires of the american people
they get voted out so yeah there is the
potential for the the ping pong but you
know we have to believe in the american
people as opposed to debasing the
systems that we have put in place that
for too long keep the will of the
american people from directing the uh
the way in which the nation should
proceed before we move on i have to ask
as a former attorney general
would merrick garland have any options
that you see if roe was overturned
you know there's the possibility i
suppose of executive actions but i think
the real
rejoinder to any decision that the court
might make would be federal legislation
all right so let's talk voting rights
and voting access what do you think the
biggest threat is today to voting rights
well it's i think it's a whole range of
things
we see voter suppression we see
gerrymandering
we see a whole range of ways in which
you're trying to keep the will of the
american people from being expressed uh
in the ballot box this is something
that's not inconsistent with what we
have seen before and it's what i talk
about uh in in the book are our
unfinished march where we have seen in
the 19th century the the 18th century
the 20th century attempts made to
empower a few and disenfranchise um the
many but i think the thing we have to
get and what i try to talk about in the
book is that ordinary people were able
to fight those people who tried to hold
on to power in an unjustified way and
actually
empower the american people the ark that
we have seen in this country has always
been to empower more people get more
people of the the right to vote and we
can do that again yeah i mean voting is
the the right that guarantees all the
others that's that's very true but on
the subject of gerrymandering uh yeah
and you're committing your career to
ending gerrymander uh mandarin and
improving voting access both parties do
it right so how do you get them to
disarm and come to the table and agree
on your solution which would be these
sort of independent commissions well see
we can't fall into some notion of
equivalency here because in a lot of
ways that's false
what princeton university said is what
the looked at the gerrymandering the
republicans did in the last cycle in
2012 and said it was the worst
gerrymandering of the last half century
now there have been some maps that
democrats have drawn this cycle that i
don't agree with new york and maryland
among them but those pale in comparison
to what republicans have done in texas
georgia potentially
in florida you're comparing apples and
oranges in a lot of ways and i'm
committed i'm committed to fighting for
fairness
because i'm also confident that if the
process is fair the democrats
progressives will do just fine we don't
have to cheat republicans have to cheat
in order to win i think they would
disagree but that's a strong statement
there you have a lot of strong ideas in
the book some of the proposals to
increase majority rule in this country
would be to term limit supreme court
justices to meter
appointments from presidents you want to
get rid of the electoral college you
want to add two new states puerto rico
and d.c you yourself in the book say
some of these ideas might seem radical
is there one that you think we should
focus on right now and could get done
oh i mean i think the possibility exists
for all of them to get done because the
reality is that
you know if you look back at our history
everything seemed like it was impossible
we had to end an american system of
racial apartheid i'm sure dr king had
moments we thought we can't pull this
off and yet they did women were not
likely to get the right to vote alice
paul somebody who we don't talk about an
awful lot led the movement and now women
have the right to vote so yeah we could
do away with the electoral college
there's a way in which you can do it
without amending the constitution uh we
can end partisan gerrymandering there
was federal legislation that could that
was considered and that should have been
passed all of these things are possible
if we limit ourselves and say they're
impossible they'll never happen if we
say they're possible and work towards
them we can make it happen and mr
attorney general i now understand why
you end the book an idealist yes i'm an
idealist because i believe in the
american experiment i believe in this
country thank you very much appreciate
you being here our unfinished march goes
on sale tomorrow